thanks to educational website brilliant
org for sponsoring this video
lots of people started following this
YouTube channel because of the blogs I
made during my PhD in atmospheric
physics at the University of Exeter I
loved doing my research and I loved
making these videos but unfortunately I
had to graduate at some point and that
necessarily meant the end of the videos
shown what doing a PhD is like however
there are lots of people out there doing
interesting PhD projects and in this new
video series I'm going to spend a few
days with a new researcher each episode
showing you what their life is like
learning a bit about them and learning
about the topic of their thesis in this
first episode I'm spending a couple of
days with kit
Ashton a friend of mine who's studying
at Goldsmiths University of London and
writing his thesis on a critically
endangered language so I grew up in
Jersey which is a Channel Islands a
British island really close to France in
fact you can see France from near where
I grew up and we have our own language
there in Jersey it's called grea it's a
dialect of Norman
it's a Latin based language but it's
endangered so there's only a few hundred
folks left that can speak it Legere yay
a long holiday Podrick keeps showing
their polar nutty's or lil de vary so as
a musician I'm interested in how music
can help keep this language alive and
that's the basis of my PhD research
which falls under the discipline of
ethnomusicology what is your musical
background you feel you're a musician
sure so I'm a singer and guitarist first
and foremost and producer a bit of bass
and whatever else and so over the years
after my undergrad I did ten or so years
as a guess as a working musician sort of
kind of session work reduction bits of
teaching but my own stuff as a
singer-songwriter and some weird random
original bands as well along the way so
a whole mix of things yeah that and then
kind of got drawn back into academia
just probably kind of once asking these
questions around music and culture that
led me actually to think about Jersey
and
what what social role using my having
jersey a few days and a haircut after
meeting at Goldsmiths we took the quick
flight over to Jersey to spend a couple
of days learning about the language and
together the Vans together kids band bad
Lebec formed part of his ph.d so I hope
with this trip you'll get a flavor of
obviously Jersey but also the community
there that speak the language and that
are engaging with the language and also
of the band and what we do and you'll
get a bit of a snapshot into the sort of
world of my fieldwork so we've got
picked up from the airport and we picked
up a car and then we got dropped off
here at our accommodation because kit
and I staying here for a couple of days
to film and so get sorted to start some
accommodation and apparently it was
arthouse Jersey who said yet we can
provide you with accommodation but
you're gonna be staying with the Jersey
Academy of Music and I thought it's
gonna be it's a PhD like you know
musicians never have that much money so
that you know alright you'll be fine
that's that's where we're staying
what kind of PhD stay somewhere with
chandeliers it's almost like the end of
2001 but it doesn't have the glowing
floor
[Music]
oh yeah it's not every filming trip that
you get to a drive around a gorgeous
island convertible but well at last I'm
going to take this little normal ride
kit no this is borrowed from my dad so
it's a scratch on this beauty is more
than my life is worth so it's a new day
we're in our fancy convertible courtesy
of kits dad and we're going to be taking
you around Jersey a little bit and
talking about the language about kits
project even maybe this bench yeah it
kind of cuts out well that's right so
kit where are we what is what's that
gorgeous view we are looking at the
beautiful Little Harbour of gory and
behind we have the castle
Montague I also known as La fiere Shorty
in JOA the old castle in the gorgeous
island of Jersey yeah it's absolutely
stunning here I mean you can't see
behind the camera is a huge beach and
the lovely class flavor there and his
ice-cream van just down there this is
how I want to film all my videos yeah
you probably call this work really but
here we are so why this project like
what was it about this specific the
language and using music that's drawn
you to doing this hmm
I'm from Jersey and my grand spokes yeah
yeah in fact you only switch the area in
French until she went to school and she
was told you have to be English now and
by the way that grea stuff is the
peasants language it's pointless you
should forget it so my didn't pass it on
to my dad my mum sighs doesn't have the
language so I was kind of aware of it
but didn't really grow up with it then
as an adult I became a musician I went
and did my first music degree in
Liverpool at Lipper and spent 10 years
just as a working musician mainly in the
UK but over it a little bit in the
States and Europe but as I came back
here the government of Jersey the
Department that's looking after Jerry
hh1 have revitalize it we're looking as
it happened at that time for a musician
to help them to use music to take six
songs into schools so it's a little paid
gig it was interesting and it connected
to this so Mike sort of growing interest
in
well languages in general but just
culture and music and that kind of thing
so I took on the project and and really
that was when I guess I was kind of a
convert to the idea of saving Jerry oh
it's it's value to our culture here it's
value actually as part of world heritage
you know as a language that has hundreds
of years of literature stories poems and
songs recipes dancers all kinds of
things that are really rich aspects of
josie's culture and yeah that really
took me on a journey that I kidding a
predictor that led to me doing a
master's in well masters in music but
really focusing on ethnomusicology
thinking about the way that music and
people make music music the way that
music and culture link which has now led
to this PhD and exploring other musical
projects across different generations
and yeah all kinds of different styles
and different ways of doing music and
linking music to language so absolutely
fascinating journey that I'm really and
privileged to have taken on and I'm
loving every bit of the way hey what's
not to love right technically you're
working on your thesis right now well
technically I'm on my youtube placement
there still counts as work oh yeah this
doesn't work so we walk down the coast a
bit you can still see Montag going over
there that thing and then over here is a
Napoleonic era kind of fortification as
well but then there's this thing and
we're actually right next to another one
here these concrete things what are
these kit so this is basically the arse
end of a German Nazi bunker cos Jersey
the Channel Islands were the only part
of the British Isles to be occupied
during the Second World War
Zillah more food ought repair do though
loved as iam Jeff Morgan from the 30th
of June 1942 the 9th of May 1945 so
nearly a year after d-day the islands
were occupied fortified and their
inhabitants existed in the unique
light-handed
occupation civilian life on the islands
during the occupation is a fascinating
topic that we really don't have time to
get into here but in the specific
it had a serious negative effect on the
local language which already dwindling
was suppressed further it's one of the
major reasons the languages so
endangered today so you can sort of see
in Ashley no that's just a little
pillbox he bet of course my family was
here my grandma granddad were here my
dad was a wee lad was three when the war
started 8 when it finished
of course the occupation years had a
real impact not just on Jersey but on
the use of Gerry 8 but also we did get
through and survived and liberation day
is crucial time in our annual calendar
so actually we're just coming up to
liberation square right now which is
going to be on our left this was the
site of really the major celebrations on
the day that the
glare from the night
that hotel the pompadour was the the
Nazi headquarters of the Navy
and this whole area was absolutely full
of people when the British Army came up
from the harbor and the Nazi flag was
taken down and the British and Joseph
active it up and my dad just live in a
flat right up there just to the left
there is a very famous photo taken from
roughly this sort of angle but looking
back that way where you can just see a
few kids hanging over the balcony up
there and one of those kids is my daddy
my projects are I've got four projects
and they're all related to how we can
raise the status of Sharia in Jersey
Society so I've got a band there singing
grea we're the only regular band in the
world right now they're sing in this
endangered language we call bad Lebec so
we've released a couple of albums we do
gigs then I took one particular song
that the band does but it's a real
traditional song it's got a real
cultural relevance in Jersey to get into
schools and taught it to 218 school kids
and then from that that pool of children
I formed a choir at 30 where it was like
25 kids from those schools and five
older kids got together form this kind
of Youth Choir and we performed that
particular song on liberation day which
is again a really important cultural day
celebrating when Jersey was liberated
from Nazi occupation at the end of the
Second World War and then the fourth
project was a collaborative songwriting
project so I got load of local bands to
write a song so either kind of take a
song they'd written or write something
original working with a Jerry a speaker
and the rule was it had to have at least
one Jerry a word in the song and then
once they've done that we got everyone
together gig gets part of a festival in
Jersey in a professional venue and
perform these songs and one night that
was called the Jersey song project so
across these four projects are basically
run them all and evaluated you're kind
of using different techniques
essentially writing what's called an
ethnography so getting a picture of the
people group so to try and work out how
effective this has been the kinds of
impacts and the kinds of ways that this
process has raised the status of Jerry
in Jersey
so this is the islands capital this is
inelia behind me which is lovely town
we're coming from the coast to do them
were filming here we've also come in to
get lunch and this is sort of supplement
it we're well kids busking
[Music]
so what your winnings
let's have a look-see it's brilliant
that's not bad all that that's down
there oh that's not enough for lunch
right hey hey so much cheaper greasy
spoon maybe or maybe though we're after
some oysters but we're wondering if you
wouldn't mind opening them for us two
for me one for
get that mischievous prune off in your
place I've not had always stirs before
so this is a new experience but I'm not
certain it's gonna be great for me
oh boy and that's it that's all the
garnish you need pretty much you can
have basco or whatever but us just the
right way to do it okay kind of like a
shot
the seafood shops it's basically a
seafood shot of zinc kidness you've been
so excited for this I'm not quite so
much so just down the hatch down down
enjoy alright so something something
[Music]
not as bad as I thought it that's
alright absolutely that's why it's so
it's lemon juice and it's just a slight
hint as see yeah and then almost like
kind of a great a little bit like a
sandy kind of just wanted a little small
pearl
of course there we go perhaps you can
have your second one okay I will stop
but why add a bit Tabasco on this one
[Music]
good stuff
lazarey and long mushy so how many
people speak show you so it's hard to
say exactly because when that
generational link was broken which is
the key thing that made it critically
endangered was a good while back so
perhaps around early 1900s really so
we've there was a middle generation
there that means now than the last
native speakers were all post with time
and age pretty much right so there and a
lot of them don't leave the house so we
can't say for sure so but we think
there's maybe two to three hundred maybe
a few more up to five hundred that are
native speakers fluent speakers that use
it regularly but also maybe a couple of
thousands maybe those the children of
that generation that understands area
but don't necessarily speak it and
others that like myself that have come
to back to it as it were that it has the
family link or that even just come to it
afresh who are learning here and you
connect them to it in a new way yes one
of the ways that people are coming to
the language is a regular session run in
the Adelphia a pub in st. Helier every
week kit wanted me to drop into the
session to try it learning a bit of the
language and to meet Garant Jennings who
works for Jersey heritage promoting
Jerry a and has been a key collaborator
with kit my name is going Jennings I
animate weekly meetups in the pub and
cafe where people can come and speak
sharing eavesdrop on Jerry ask questions
play games do some activities learn some
phrases and generally get in contact
with the Jerry speaking of community
Mona we get on it check it tour north on
the way Simon
most what swag
come on get em comic play yeah so the
sessions being run with really
informative it's a mix I have just a
casual conversation you know people
being introduced to me the words
occasionally dropping into English but
mostly in a target might so it's
completely impenetrable like okay I'm
okay at French but this is so different
that I can get things like in things
like that grammar is just so different
so I I can't really engage kit of course
in the other hand can hold its own
conversation and some of these people
are they're not fluent because any
people who have fluent are parts of time
and age and you know grew up with
language but some of these guys are
getting on for bras NUMA those that
[Music]
thank you convolution GP say don't ask
Paul select
GG are so good
calmly Schanke pistols are so full of
sullen hello Gigi don't only pacing each
mm takes one who possess to salt it and
the other he craps a particulate
supposed to be liberal and tolerant with
an extra league judgmental it's a lovely
little community of people we know
absolutely passionate about it and most
of them are people who are not from the
islands you're keen to learn the local
heritage it's just it feels precarious
right you know the people over there on
that table and in this one pup in the
centre of the capital of the island when
we went up to the bar for a half fine
ingeras over I didn't get it right but I
asked for one and the bar people have no
idea like no clear by Jarius between
them so it does feel like a language of
the right on the edge
this is like the comeback the promotion
that from near extinction
even love even more even love
love even more
we welcome bunny so we've come to the
western end of Jersey
that's like Xavier the lighthouse there
we've got someone's bay here to get some
dinner also because it's gorgeous
but over here in that distant haze is an
exotic islands known as Guernsey well be
taking the first of my PhD projects my
band bad Levesque - a lovely little
festival called veil earth bear will be
performing in a Norman castle and I'm
coming - it's an excuse for a holiday
basically you know we're not gonna see a
typical week for you you're not spending
your entire PhD in Jersey doing this
it's part of the fieldwork but so what
does what does a normal week look like
for you in your PhD so I'm currently in
the writing up place so I've done
although my fieldwork is ongoing in the
sense of I'm still embedded in that
community and relevant things coming up
could end up with my thesis I've got
enough data to write up my PhD so now
most of the way through writing so my
typical week is me in front of a
computer just just bush you know getting
tearing my hair out and pushing out
another few thousand birds and delete a
few thousand words so but then sometimes
coming into the library I might come in
supervision as well of course it's be
most at home but I'm still at the moment
mostly work at home so Guernsey is just
like Jersey if you haven't been here
it's like rural France
you haven't been to rural France it's
kind of like paradise really so we're
staying overnight here for the festival
in what is the Guernsey Scout hut which
is just behind me here this is gorgeous
old farmhouse that was built than if you
can see this about the door in 1723 it's
like thick walled lovely old farmhouse
that's been converted and a band is
actually rehearsing outside now
[Music]
[Music]
yes we so we've just arrived in the main
bit of the festival that's the stage
over there so if you've not been to a
kind of folky environment themed
festival like this one in the UK they're
all basically the same they've all got a
bunch of bunting everywhere a whole load
of people here who are just kind of
chilling not causing any trouble
enjoying themselves a lot of them our
beards as a large angle on climate
change and extinction rebellion and a
bit of an echo chamber maybe and a
really interesting variety of music and
art and food and drink and so lovely
chill atmosphere
lots of kids like a family kind of vibe
not a bad view for a festival from the
Technos castle like an alien from more
of the world's just landed over there
instantly support it's just about to go
on how are you feeling about this do
you've done this loads of times yeah you
know no super exciting to be on its leg
yeah we have done load of gigs but this
is our first big proper gig in Guernsey
yeah the beautiful festival is really
meaningful as well because Errol one of
the founders just recently died we're so
proud to bring our culture our language
here and laugh makes music and hopefully
get people dancing
[Music]
Thank You general make some noise from
Jersey
wash your paws on ya young tree
[Music]
they get warm ideally penalty
that bomb I can't say get more money
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
she chose replace EBUS truly chief or a
chocolate peanut confess mantis polygon
unana get been told
move
[Music]
that bang
[Music]
come
[Music]
[Music]
you're not cheat on enough to cheat and
stop into you he's so pushy that you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
they can use that bomb
[Music]
oh I get it
[Music]
Marisa man they play so kids just done
his set and there's another band on now
I asked if I could put my tripod
somewhere and they were like yeah if it
were not kit and kit weirdness Castle
right but Kenzie was also occupied so
there's an addition made to the castle
under here she throws their doors in
ears
[Music]
[Music]
in space how did it go it went so well I
mean sure that could have been a bigger
crowd but hey the the folks that were
there had I think a good performance out
of us and they were lovely gave us a
really lovely energy back that's what
it's all about music creates that's
connection between people and you know
if the language is part of that then
that's all what helps to keep it all
alive and so yeah that's my thesis in a
nutshell right so therefore thinking
about what's next and where it goes I
can take that and hopefully sure write
it up in my thesis but hopefully it's
actually something alive and living that
can keep going maybe inspire other folks
with other languages that might be
working with music as well and yeah it's
something that is beyond just a sort of
dry bit of research so that's what's
brilliant about this
[Music]
naturally this video couldn't go into a
lot of detail on everything in kits PhD
but if you found his research
interesting then you can check out his
YouTube channel
Kip Ashton musicology which is all about
music how it works and what it's for and
if you are interested in doing a PhD
yourself then a great place to start is
this video sponsor brilliant dog doing a
PhD is all about independent study
pursuing your academic interests and
pushing your own knowledge forwards and
brilliant is an educational website that
is all about all of those things it
allows you to improve or practice your
knowledge of topics in science maths and
logic and it does this by getting you to
apply your knowledge solving practice
problems personally I think the best way
of learning is learning by doing and
that is what brilliant is all about in
particular if you have five minutes
spare in your daily commute then use it
to learn some new science or maths
through brilliance daily challenges
every day brilliant post an intriguing
problem which will require you to flex
your brain muscles to solve think of it
like a small daily workout just for your
brain if you go to brilliant org slash
Simon Clark then you can sign up for
free and not only support this series
but if you're one of the first 200
people to do so you can get 20% off your
premium annual subscription thank you to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
of course thank you to kit for agreeing
to be featured I'd also like to thank
chase and arthouse Jersey for providing
us with funding and accommodation if
you'd like to learn more about Gerry A's
then there's a link in the description
to la fiesta jelly where you can learn
more about the language lastly if you
are a PhD student watching this and you
think your project will make for an
interesting video in this series then
there's also information in the
description about how to get in touch
with me because I would love this series
to feature as many different PhDs
covering different projects hosted at
different universities as possible so if
you think that's you then get in touch
thanks very much for watching this video
and I'll see you in the next one